also you have a uh you have a child you
have a son or a daughter
i have a son matthew edward who is
he's seven and a half months i actually
you have him with you
he's so he's right here in my pocket
yeah i carry him here
this is really the new high-tech thing
this is like the home shopping that's an
incredible baby
it's made of a high-density polymer now
if everybody's real quiet
what have you done eufine
what is that that you carry that around
everywhere what is that that's
that is he had his vocal cords removed
oh and there's a picture of him right
there uh now that's very nice i would
think
that you what other things have you
recorded you just just uh your son's
saying dada
well yeah it took 172 hours to get him
to actually
say just say dada right it was
everything i had to bribe him with a lot
of
strained mush i would think the fun
thing would do would get your your baby
to cry and then take that thing into a
movie theater and just jack up the
volume
annoy everybody exactly well he does
that on his own he was he was
he's actually good we fly uh flew out
here from l.a he was fine in the flight
was flirting with uh sarah jessica
parker
who can blame him wow what a lucky baby
he's hanging out with celebrities
already that's fun yeah
now listen let me ask you something is
it hard i mean we're probably about the
same age and
you've got a kid that's something that i
can't imagine is it difficult
ah what no it's yes i have children
everywhere i don't know about them
no i would say it's it's got to be hard
it's you know what it's really not if
you get to the point in your life where
you're ready for it and
and you know i like to stay at home with
my wife watching television we're sort
of boring and so when you're not going
out
you want to have somebody else to spend
your time with and you get to a certain
age you start thinking about
you're not going to be young forever and
you want to have somebody there when
you're gone this is nice and depressing
isn't it no
no it's why is that depressing is that
depressing do people find that too
no no good no i'm glad that's a nice
that's supposed to be a nice sentiment
no i've always we're all going to wither
and die
one day right uh we want something there
when you're when you
to carry on and i've always wanted to
have a big family we're going to start
maybe another
in about a year year and a half there
are six in my family try and match that
six kids i don't think my wife would
want
six well you see you know for us we just
sit back talk
anytime you're ready honey is the baby
pretty well
behaved no problems easy to get the baby
to sleep when it starts crying like a
maniac no he's great he's got a really
good personality he's
he's a champ i'm real lucky what do you
do if he's just not like it's
it's five in the morning and he just
won't stop crying
honey honey the baby's crying
no it's not true i get up i swear no i'm
just kidding
i swear to you men and women are equal
yes
but you don't have any special
techniques or anything i heard you had a
technique no that's true
i do have a technique uh he has
different levels of crying
the minor crying my wife's great at but
if it's turning purple
crying i'm the only guy that can solve
it andy does that he gets bright purple
oh you do this yeah when he cries
i'd rather not talk about it so what do
you do
i i sing the national anthem
to him seriously i i don't know why
it is but the only thing that stops him
from crying is for me to sing like a
real
phony operatic baritone as loud as you
can
the national oh say can you see
[Applause]
oh yeah
and that calms him right down oh yeah
that would that would calm me down oh i
want to go right to sleep that's
right out i don't know why and we i
watched laker games with him on my lap
the minute the national anthem comes
comes on out like a light right
this is going to wreak havoc in his
adult life right listen
best of luck though congratulations on
the stand and uh best of luck with it
and thanks for coming by
it's nice talking to you love love
everybody